ein land jahrzehntelang geteilt
und wenn's winston churchill vom
eisernen vorhang sprach meinte er genau
das
ein knallhartes untersuchungsgefängnis
sie sorgten dafür dass du den anderen
gefangenen nie begegnest du warst total
isoliert
[Musik]
ein insel idyll mit unterirdischen
bunkersystem
je weiter man vordringt desto
verwinkelter werden die tunnel
es ist eine riesige anlage
[Musik]
eine geheime forschungseinrichtung
warum baut man so etwas und versteckte
es dann
ich finde das sehr unheimlich
und ein verbotener ort nahe der
hauptstadt
wer immer auch hier war ließ alters sehr
plötzlich zurück die frage ist warum die
eile
[Musik]
ein blick auf das was hinter der
berliner mauer geschah
[Musik]
imposante bauwerke heute verlassen
geheimnisvolle ruinen die die geschichte
widerspiegeln
einige stammen aus dunkleren zeiten und
doch sind sie zeugnisse von menschlichem
einfallsreichtum und erfindergeist
jedes hat eine einzigartige geschichte
die hier erzählt wird
[Musik]
1989 zerfällt die sowjetunion
der fall der berliner mauer führt zur
deutschen wiedervereinigung
viele hatten schon nicht mehr daran
geglaubt
als sich der eiserne vorhang öffnet
kommen die relikte kommunistischer
herrschaft zum vorschein
gefängnisse spionage zentralen
regierungsgebäude orte zu denen
ostdeutsche bürger normalerweise keinen
zugang hatten
im berliner bezirk lichtenberg räumt
eine abweisende mauer einer ansonsten
unauffällige straße
wie das tragen wir nicht welche
grausamkeiten sich hinter solche mauern
abspielte
sie wirkt bedrohlich und man spürt
sofort dass man nicht dahinter sein
möchte
was mussten menschen getan haben um an
einem ort wie diesem eingesperrt zu
werden
im inneren
gitterstäbe und lange flure mit schweren
grauen türen
sie sorgten dafür dass du den anderen
gefangenen nie begegnest du warst total
isoliert
nur wenige kilometer entfernt steht ein
harmlos wirkende gebäudekomplex
die flure und büros waren absichtlich so
bieder und gesichtslos gehalten
das könnte der firmensitz eines
drittklassigen büro
zugleich wirken einige räume wie die
kulissen eines spionage films
da gab es jede menge altmodisches zeug
und diverse elektronische geräte
dort wurde nichts produziert in diesem
büro saßen schnüffler die sich in dinge
einmischen die sie nichts angehen
in welchem zusammenhang stehen diese
beiden gebäudekomplexe
lehrbetrieb sie
noch heute lässt ihr anblick viele
menschen erschaudern
[Musik]
zum beispiel den ehemaligen häftling
peter kreuz
1981 wird er damals 22 jährige verhaftet
und ohne weitere erklärung mit einem
solchen transporter weggeschafft
in einer zelle so winzig wie ein
kleiderschrank
als sie die tür geschlossen war es
stockfinster es war der blanke horror
in meinem leben hatte ich solche angst
nach vier stunden im transporter landet
in einem gefängnis
doch was hat er verbrochen und wer
verriet ihn an die behörden
aber auch die übrige staatsgrenze der
ddr war streng bewachte und stark
befestigt
coop hatte versucht über die
tschechoslowakische grenze zu fliegen
es war praktisch unmöglich aus der ddr
in den westen zu weisen egal ob direkt
in die bundesrepublik oder über die
tschechoslowakei oder sonst wer
[Musik]
die ddr schottet sich als staat immer
mehr ab
die ursachen dafür gehen zurück bis zur
potsdamer konferenz im august 1945
damals wird deutschland in vier besetzte
zonen aufgeteilt
die ostzone kommt unter sowjetische
kontrolle
mitglieder des kommunistischen
ddr-regimes lernten schnell dass die
führung in moskau unkritischen und
bedingungslosen gehorsam erwartete
mit ihrer kommunistischen hingabe wollte
die ddr-führung stahl die noch
übertreffen sie wollte eine neue
sozialistische gesellschaft erschaffen
dazu musste sie alle lebensbereiche der
bürgerinnen und bürger kontrollieren und
das war die aufgabe der stasi
[Musik]
dies ist die zentrale
untersuchungshaftanstalt der
staatssicherheit
gehört zu den zahllosen inhaftierten das
hauptziel der stasi ist es die 17
millionen ddr bürger zu kontrollieren
und ihre flucht in den westen zu
verhindern
die staatssicherheit hatte über eine
viertel million mitarbeiter im grunde
war das eine staatspolizei die das
kommunistische system der ddr aufrecht
erhielt es war ein system der totalen
unterdrückung
die gefangenen leben in totaler
isolation
nur meine mutter wusste dass ich vorräte
zu fliehen ich fragte mich immer weiß
sie überhaupt dass sie noch am leben bin
das kontaktverbot zu familienangehörigen
ist nur eines von vielen druckmitteln
der stasi
die leute in isolationshaft die
inhaftierten wussten nicht ob tag oder
nacht und wann sie etwas zu essen
bekommen wird und sie wurden am schlafen
gehindert
kopf des stasi apparates ist dieser mann
erich mielke
er war minister für staatssicherheit ein
biederer unscheinbarer bürokrat der eine
der furchterregendsten geheimpolizei in
der welt leitete
nur ein paar minuten von der haftanstalt
entfernt liegt mir chris dienstsitz das
nervenzentrum der staatssicherheit
das war das büro des ministers für
staatssicherheit
das herz des systems das herz des bösen
wenn sie mich fragen
es in gewisser hinsicht war das stasi
hauptquartier das wichtigste gebäude der
ddr von hier aus wurde die gesamte
bevölkerung überwacht sie sammelten
intimste details aus dem leben der
menschen
1961 wird der bau fertiggestellt die
machtvolle basis für einen
überwachungsstaat wie ihn die welt noch
nicht gesehen hat
sie wollten herauskriegen was in deiner
wohnung deinem haus seiner fabrik und
deiner schule geschah ihre spione waren
überall egal ob zu hause oder bei der
arbeit der staat sieht immer zu
zwei bis drei prozent der bevölkerung
wurden dafür bezahlt ihre nachbarn
klassenkameraden und kollegen zu
bespitzeln die informationen landeten in
umfangreichen akten alles was der staat
über seine 17 millionen bürger
herausfand wurde im stasi hauptquartier
aufbewahrt
doch ende der 80er jahre wächst der
widerstand gegen das system
verzweifelt versucht die staatsmacht die
alte ordnung aufrechtzuerhalten
zu dieser zeit ist auch der spätere
russische präsident wladimir putin in
der ddr
nutzte die stasi oft für spionage
operationen im westen er überwachte und
dirigierte aber auch die bekämpfung aus
deutscher dissidenten durch die
staatssicherheit
wladimir putin leitete als offizier
damals ein büro des kgb in dresden
die zeit des überwachungsstaats läuft
unweigerlich ab was aber soll mit dem
umfangreichen stasi archiv geschehen
[Musik]
im januar 1990 geschah etwas
bemerkenswertes
es gab das gerücht dass die stasi
unterlagen vernichtet werden sollten
bürgerrechtler wollten das verhindern
und besetzten verschiedene
bezirksstellen sie wollten die zeugnisse
der unterdrückung bewahren
denn ohne diese wäre es kaum möglich
gewesen die verbrechen von jahrzehnten
zu dokumentieren
schließlich wird die haftanstalt
geschlossen und die stasi aufgelöst
erich mielke kommt vor gericht und wird
zu sechs jahren haft verurteilt
1992 werden die stasi-unterlagen der
öffentlichkeit zugänglich gemacht
auch peter kreuz erhält einsicht in
seine akte
das ist meine stasi akte dieses foto
wurde kurz nach meiner verhaftung in der
untersuchungshaftanstalt gemacht
nach dem tod seines bruders im jahr 2012
macht kolb eine erschütternde entdeckung
das ist die akte meines bruders aus ihr
geht etwas hervor was ich mir nie im
leben hätte vorstellen
kreuz findet heraus dass sein bruder ein
stasi spitzel war der ihn und seine
familie ausspioniert hat
[Musik]
die mauer ist längst geschichte die
opfer und täter des unrechtsstaats aber
leben immer noch im wiedervereinten
deutschland
und die erinnerungen sind noch längst
nicht verblasst die konnten bürger die
für die stasi gearbeitet haben leben
immer noch mitten unter uns das gibt mir
ein gutes gefühl
mit hilfe moderner computertechnologie
soll nach und nach 600 millionen
geschredderte papierschnipsel der staat
zusammengesetzt werden
für viele sind die verbrechen des
brutalen polizeistaat immer noch
erschreckend aktuell
sie sehnen sich nach einem abschluss
wollen wissen wer sie verraten hat und
warum
[Musik]
vor der küste kroatiens im
kristallklaren wasser der adria liegt
die malerische insel wies aber der
schöne schein trügt
ist ein touristenmagnet und das zu recht
aber wer genauer hinsieht dort dinge die
nicht ins idyllische bild passen
die
beliebte aus einer anderen zeit
wenn man um die insel segelt wirkt sie
wie ein mediterranes urlaubsparadies
aber dann stößt man auf eine seltsame
betonkonstruktion
wie ein schlüsselloch dass in ihr
inneres führt
[Musik]
was war der zweck dieses rätselhafte
baus von außen ist nicht viel zu
erkennen
[Musik]
je tiefer man vordringen erste
verwinkelter werden die tunnel
es ist eine riesige anlage aber welchem
zweck sie diente und wer sie gebaut hat
bleibt erst mal ein rätsel
[Musik]
der fremdenführer tomislav milans die
strategische bedeutung der insel
unsere insel liegt mitten in der adria
sie war immer sehr umkämpft
denn wer wies kontrollierte
kontrollierte die adria
schon in der antike bei den alten
griechen und römern er kannte und
schätzte man den hohen strategischen
wert der insel
nach dem ersten weltkrieg wird wies teil
des neu gegründeten staates jugoslawien
das land entwickelt sich zur
kommunistischen republik und spielt als
neutraler staat während des kalten
krieges eine wichtige rolle
der anlage aufwies kommt dabei eine
besondere bedeutung zu
das ist der geschütz stand er wurde 1960
errichtet und gehörte zu den ersten
militäreinrichtungen aufwies
ohne den kalten krieg wären die tunnel
und höhlen vermutlich nie entstanden
sie wurden gebaut um die insel und ganz
jugoslawien vor möglichen nuklearen
angriffen zu schützen
[Musik]
dies gibt es solche stellungen in allen
himmelsrichtungen
die insel soll der rundum abgesichert
sein
dies ist eine geheime kommunistische
militärbasis 120 kilometer langes tunnel
ab und verbindet bunker höhlen und
geschützt stellungen
[Musik]
auf der nordseite liegt das herzstück
der anlage
die beeindruckendste konstruktion ist
vermutlich ein gigantischer unter der
tief in die insel hinein reicht
von wasser aus ist sehr gut zu erkennen
aber nicht aus der luft
der bunker erhält den code-namen ja
stock zu deutsch hunger
u boote wie die server ein mit torpedos
bewaffnet des jugoslawischen
kriegsschiff waren hier versteckt
der hummer tunnel ist 150 meter lang 17
meter hoch und sechs meter tief er wurde
in den felsen gesprengt sprengstoff rein
und bumm
[Musik]
wozu aber braucht das kommunistische
jugoslawien die adria festung
wirklich nur um sich vor der
militärischen macht des westens zu
schützen im mittelpunkt der geschichte
steht staatschef josip tito er spielt
ein gefährliches politisches spiel
[Musik]
während des zweiten weltkriegs kämpfte
josip tito als partisanen führer gegen
die nazis und das sehr erfolgreich
nach dem krieg etablierte er in
jugoslawien eine ganz eigene form des
kommunismus
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg wird europa
vom eisernen vorhang geteilt
bis 1948 waren tito und stalin
verbündete
doch tito wollte verhindern dass die usa
asien sich zu einer sowjetischen kolonie
im stile der ddr oder polens entwickelt
deshalb brach er 1948 offiziell mit
stalin und erklärte keine sowjetischen
militärstützpunkte und truppen in
jugoslawien zuzulassen
so spielte ost und west clever
gegeneinander aus er schuf mit der
sogenannten blockfreien bewegung einen
dritten weg
mit
tieto paktiert wieder mit den sowjets
noch mit dem westen das macht sein land
zu einem potenziellen ziel für eine
invasion womöglich gar für einen
sowjetische nuklear angriff
deshalb benötigt jugoslawien wirksame
schutzvorkehrungen
[Musik]
im krieg hatte er gelernt stützpunkte
über das ganze land zu verteilen
im fall eines sowjetischen angriffs
konnte er sich so in die berge und
stützpunkte zurückziehen und von dort
aus widerstand leisten
dies kommt dabei eine schlüsselrolle zu
während des zweiten weltkriegs hatte
tito von hier aus den widerstand gegen
die nazis organisiert
[Musik]
hat er für tieto immer besondere
bedeutung er machte die insel zu einem
hauptstützpunkt der jugoslawischen
marine
die tunnel und höhen aufwies sind also
vor allem ein bollwerk gegen die
mächtige rote armee
aber wurden sie jemals gebraucht und
wann wurden sie aufgegeben
titus kaltblütiger machtpoker hat für
die bürger des landes gravierende
konsequenzen
ditto setzte seine vorstellungen
gnadenlos um er duldete keine opposition
war ein echter diktator und
verantwortlich für viele tragödien 13
seiner familienangehörigen wurden
getötet als eine partisanen in zagreb
einmarschierten
tietos gnadenloses regime hat
hunderttausende auf dem gewissen
aber was wird aus seiner versteckten
insel festung
während die sowjets jemals in
jugoslawien einmarschiert hätten sie die
insel einnehmen und als raketenbasis
nutzen können
das gesamte system war nicht offensiv
sondern ausschließlich defensiv
ausgerichtet es sollte einen angriff auf
jugoslawien verhindern es war teil einer
sehr erfolgreichen abschreckungspolitik
plan geht auf
die insel festung leistet ihren beitrag
dazu dass die sowjets jugoslawien
niemals angreifen dafür erwachsen ganz
andere bedrohungen
nach titos tod fehlte plötzlich die
harte hand die jugoslawien zusammen
gehalten hatte
der vielvölkerstaat zerbrach alte
feindschaften flammten auf und führten
in mehreren regionen zu kriegen
gegen die brutalen bürgerkriege der
neunzigerjahre helfen keine
militärstützpunkte
jugoslawien zerfleischt sich selbst und
zerfällt schließlich in sieben zum teil
ethnisch getrennte starten
[Musik]
die insel wie es gehört heute zum
unabhängigen kroatien
nach dem jahrelangen konflikt will das
neue land nur noch frieden titus
stützpunkt in der adria wird geschlossen
als sonniges urlaubsparadies ist wie es
heute weit entfernt von titus düsteren
kriegs visionen nur die beton ruinen
erinnern noch daran dass die geschichte
auch ganz anders hätte verlaufen können
[Musik]
u
boot stützpunkt ist ein symbol für die
nukleare bedrohung die auf dem höhepunkt
des kalten kriegs tatsächlich existierte
an einem see 40 kilometer östlich von
berlin liegt ein unspektakulärer
gebäudekomplex
von außen ist von den dunklen
geheimnissen dieses ortes nichts zu
spüren
bis man ein abgelegenes unscheinbares
haus betritt
[Musik]
darin befindet sich ein spartanisches
büro mit altmodischer einrichtung es ist
der eingang zu einer geheimen welt
es wirkt wie ein typisches sportgelände
aber darunter versteckt vor neugierigen
blicken befindet sich ein geheimer
bunker
mächtige industriemaschinen sorgten
einst für die stromversorgung
das equipment lässt vermuten dass hier
eine überwachungstätigkeit stattfand
voller monitore und abhörgeräte ein ort
wie aus einem spionagethriller
wozu das ganze equipment
wer oder was wurde hier überwacht
einen ersten hinweis finden wir hinter
einer ungewöhnlichen tür
so eine tür würde man eher in einem
u-boot erwarten
können sie sich vorstellen da
runterzugehen
durch so eine druckluft schleuse zu
kommen muss irgendwie einschüchternd
gewesen sein
dahinter ist ein großer saal voller
trainingsgeräte
und ein weiterer raum mit medikamenten
andere zimmer sind inzwischen verwaist
warum baut man so etwas und verstecktes
dann ich finde das sehr unheimlich
so unwahrscheinlich es klingen mag diese
ort war einst ein schauplatz des
wettstreits zwischen ost und west
während des kalten krieges organisierte
die ddr von hier aus einen
stellvertreterkrieg der in sportarenen
auf der ganzen welt ausgetragen wurde
die kommunistischen athleten kämpften
nicht nur für die ehre ihres landes
sie kämpften auch für die ehre der
ganzen kommunistischen welt für ddr
athleten gilt das ganz besonders denn
die ostdeutschen hielten sich für die
speerspitze des kommunismus
der dreimalige kajak olympiasieger
torsten gutsche erinnert sich an die
damaligen rivalitäten
der erfolgreichsten karl nationen damals
in der welt es gab immer einen einen
kampf zwischen den
jüngeren sportlern zwischen den ddr
sportlern zwischen den russischen boden
die auch sehr stark waren die ddr war
ein kleines land und man wollte
natürlich als sozialistischer staat dem
kapitalismus beweisen dass der
sozialismus dem kapitalismus überlegen
ist und das hat man natürlich immer
versucht mit mit den sport
ist die ostdeutschen athleten waren sehr
erfolgreich wieder und wieder gewann sie
bei internationalen wettkämpfen
[Musik]
zwischen 1976 und 1986 holt die ddr bei
weltmeisterschaften und olympischen
spielen mehr medaillen als jede andere
nation
gemessen an ihrer bevölkerungszahl ein
wahres wunder doch dahinter steckt ein
finsteres geheimnis
[Musik]
viele ostdeutsche athleten waren mit
steroiden folge punkt
das führte zu leberschäden störungen des
re produktionssystems und geburtsfehlern
das wirkte sich noch jahrzehnte später
aus
die gesundheit dieser athleten wurde im
namen von ruhm und propaganda aufs spiel
gesetzt
die ostdeutsche regierung trägt dafür
die verantwortung
1974 beschließt sie das so genannte
stadtplan thema 14 25 dass die
doping-praxis landesweit koordiniert
doch die kontrollen bei internationalen
wettbewerben werden immer strenger
das olympische komitee und die
internationalen verbände führten
bluttests 1
das erschwerte den gebrauch von
steroiden
[Musik]
trotzdem sind die ostdeutschen sportler
den kontrolleuren immer eine nasenlänge
voraus und zwar dank der forschung in
kienbaum trainingszentrum
es war schon ein sehr geheimer ort und
zwar
unter sportler schon
was ganz besonderes ist eine große ehre
dass man an einem
geheimen ort trainieren durfte
es war sehr beeindruckend
das programm wurde als alternative zu
den steroiden entwickelt die den
ostdeutschen so gute dienste geleistet
hat
fertig gestellt im jahr 1979 ist das
trainingszentrum mit all den üblichen
geräten ausgestattet die man an so einem
ort erwarten würde die wichtigste rolle
aber spielt der geheimen bunker
was macht ihn so besonders
[Musik]
die ostdeutschen haben ein
trainingszentrum gebaut in dem die
bedingungen simuliert werden konnten wie
sie in großer höhe herrschen also wenig
sauerstoff und niedriger luft
ein ventilationssystem pumpt so lange
die luft ab bis eindruck wie in 4000
metern höhe herrscht
das steigert die produktion roter
blutkörperchen und somit auch die
leistungsfähigkeit
[Applaus]
das konzept war dass die athleten sich
an die geringe sauerstoffzufuhr gewöhnen
unter normalen bedingungen würden ihr
blut und gewebe dann jede menge extra
sauerstoff zugeführt bekommen so sollte
die siegesserien der ostdeutschen
weitergehen
die sportler aber zahlen einen hohen
preis
es war sehr anstrengend hier zu
trainieren
schon alleine durch die durch die durch
die höhe durch den luftdruck hat sich
das alles noch mal ja noch mal verstärkt
gegenüber dem training draußen und es
war ja sehr eintönig er drin das licht
war nicht sehr angenehm mehr drin die
luft war nicht sehr angenehm hier
drinnen die atmosphäre waren nicht sehr
angenehme drinnen
sie trainierten zwei wochen lang zwölf
stunden pro tag und das ohne natürliches
licht und wussten dabei nicht wie sich
der höhenluft bunker langfristig auf
ihre gesundheit auswirkt
athleten konnten einem leid tun sie
waren zwar erfolgreich aber sie waren
eben auch labor
überwacht werden nicht nur die
sportlichen leistungen die stasi
interessiert sich auch für alle anderen
aktivitäten ihrer top athleten
[Musik]
in der ddr gab es ja auch ein thema
staatssicherheit und deswegen war man
auch bei manchen personen die man nicht
kannte doch etwas vorsichtiger und das
war das was ich erzählt habe mit den
kameras man wusste nicht so richtig was
hier was hier wirklich gefilmt wurde was
auch aufgezeichnet wurde von der stimme
her
einige der athleten stehen dem
überwachungsstaat kritisch gegenüber
mehr als 600 fliehen in den westen
[Musik]
viele von ihnen werden als verräter
gebrandmarkt und bis zur
wiedervereinigung im jahr 1990 von der
stasi verfolgt
[Musik]
einige behaupten in kienbaum mit gewalt
oder ohne eigene kenntnis gedopt worden
zu sein
torsten gutsche sagt er habe
glücklicherweise nie steroide
verabreicht bekommen und auch sonst
nichts mit doping zu tun gehabt
doch er musste unter extremen
bedingungen seinen körper stellen und
dabei unangenehme erfahrungen machen
und hier drinnen war sehr beklemmend
sehr eng und man war auch ständig unter
kontrolle
also man warum doch sehr ruhig und hat
er wenig erzählt weil man nicht wusste
was hier abgehört wurden was gefilmt
wird
und ob das auch gesundheitlich so toll
was wir gemacht haben vor allen dingen
für den rücken sind viele fragen die ich
nicht beantworten kann
[Musik]
heute fungiert kienbaum als olympisches
und paralympisches trainingszentrum
[Musik]
der unterirdische bunker ist immer noch
da ein mahnmal das an eine andere zeit
erinnert
in gewisser hinsicht wurde hier
pionierarbeit geleistet
man hört oft das top athleten oder
fußballteams trainingscamps in den
bergen veranstalten die bedingungen die
da oben herrschen wurden in diesem
unterirdischen bunker nachgestellt
südlich von berlin am rand von zossen
steht ein verlassener gebäude komplex
[Musik]
durch die nebel kommen geradezu
palastartiges gebäude zum vorschein
auf den ersten blick ist die architektur
von altmodischer opulenz
plötzlich taucht im innenhof ein
seltsames rundes gebäude auf sagt roger
ein wahrer stilbruch
der ungewöhnliche betonbau ist mit
auffälligen wandmalereien verziert
plötzlich stehen sie vor diesen gebäuden
und statuen die so gar nicht nach
mitteleuropa zu passen scheinen
offenbar hat hier eine andere kultur
ihre spuren hinterlassen
mehrere hundert gebäude sind über das
gelände verteilt
sie haben endlose flure und verlassene
zimmer
[Musik]
das theater der pool und einige andere
einrichtungen deuten auf etwas ziviles
hin die landkarten und wandgemälde
lassen dagegen eher etwas militärisches
vermuten
die siedlung ist komplett von der
außenwelt abgeschnitten die häuser sind
dem verfall preisgegeben sie wirken wie
aus der zeit gefallen wer hat die anlage
errichtet und warum wurde sie aufgegeben
wer auch immer hier war ließ alles sehr
plötzlich zurück die frage ist warum die
eile
es geschieht an einem kalten märz tag
des jahres 1994 die bewohner erhalten
den abmarsch befehl
sofort herrscht großes durcheinander
jürgen naumann der heutige hausmeister
ist mittendrin
da ist dann ein gewisses chaos
ausgebrochen also da war keiner dieser
disziplin man konnte hier alles großmann
hat alles angebot man hat benzin angebot
man konnte sich eine kalaschnikow kaufen
[Musik]
die leute hier sind teil einer kleinen
elite
jahrzehntelang hat niemand sonst zutritt
zu dem gelände
sie besetzten das areal und errichteten
eine mauer kein ddr bürger durfte da
rein
mehr als 600 gebäude auf einer fläche
von sechs quadratkilometern
ein erstaunlich großes areal
was also spielt sich hier ab
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg errichten die
alliierten vier besatzungszonen in
deutschland
die sowjetunion übernimmt den osten des
landes und braucht kasernen um ihre
truppen zu stationieren
[Musik]
für die rote armee war es das einfachste
bestehende strukturen der wehrmacht zu
übernehmen
als die sowjets im april 1945 eintrafen
fanden sie hier einen riesigen
militärischen komplex vor sie brauchten
nur einzuziehen
dies ist wünsdorf das hauptquartier der
russischen armee in ostdeutschland
[Musik]
außerhalb der sowjetunion gab es
nirgends eine größere konzentration von
sowjetischen soldaten
für deutsche ist der zutritt streng
verboten aber
einige finden trotzdem einen weg hinein
die ganze ortschaft waren mit einer
mauer einer abgegrenzten da gab es immer
eingänge kleine worten und wo so ein
soldat stand und wenn man diesen
soldaten mal was zu kommen lassen hat
dann hat da in rein gelassen habe und
dann konnte man hier unbehelligt
einkaufen gehen und hat viel mit
zigaretten gekauft euro sag ich mal
alkohol maja recht kostengünstig für
viele die gerne ein getrunken haben
ende der 80er jahre ist wünsdorf mehr
als nur ein armeestützpunkt es ist eine
verbotene stadt
lebten bis zu 75.000 männer frauen und
kinder
die siedlung wurde klein moskau genannt
es gab geschäfte schulen
freizeiteinrichtungen und sogar eine
tägliche zugverbindung in die
sowjetische hauptstadt hier in wünsdorf
zum beispiel
diesen areal was das kulturelle zentrum
der sowjetischen bürger hier lebenden
bürger war sah da wurden ja ständig
aufführung genauso in dem großen gebäude
was hier hinter mir ist da waren dann
ausstellung museen gedenkt räume und
dergleichen
mit dem ende des kalten krieges aber
sind die tage von klein moskau gezählt
michael gorbatschows perestroika politik
kann den kollaps der sowjetunion nicht
aufhalten
1989 fällt die mauer nach 40 jährigem
bestehen ist die ddr geschichte
der unterhalt der sowjetischen
einrichtungen in ostdeutschland kostete
viel geld
als die sowjetische wirtschaft
zusammenbrach wusste das militär
abgezogen werden
nach der deutschen wiedervereinigung
erklärt sich russland bereit bis ende
1994 sämtliche truppen abzuziehen der
rückzug aber verläuft keineswegs in
geordneten bahnen für die wünsdorfer
soldaten und ihre familien beginnt eine
chaotische zeit
die langjährige rigide ordnung der roten
armee zerfiel der abzug der truppen war
nicht gut organisiert
jürgen naumann erinnert sich an die
schlechte stimmung die damals in
wünsdorf herrscht
eine verkaufsstelle leiterin mit der
recht gesprochen ob ich kommen dorthin
zu ihr saß in ihrem büro und hat geweint
sie hat zwei söhne kleinen kinder gehabt
und wo ich das dann zum beispiel
erfahren habe was den passiert wo sie
sagte wir müssen in zwei tagen hier weg
ich weiß nicht wohin auch
im 1600 kilometer entfernten moskau
herrscht chaos für boris jelzin den
ersten präsidenten des neuen russischen
staates stellen die offiziere aus
wilnsdorf eine bedrohung dar
den hat er schon einen putschversuch
abgewehrt als all diese hochrangigen
offiziere in die heimat zurückkehrten
ließ er sie übers ganze land verteilen
um das risiko eines weiteren
militärputsches zu verringern
den offizieren der roten armee gefiel es
in ostdeutschland ihr lebensstandard
dort war bedeutend höher als daheim in
russland
man konnte ganz andere sachen kaufen als
im rest des landes es gab schwimmbäder
und sportplätze man merkte gar nicht
dass man in der ddr war
außerhalb der garnisonsstadt ist der
lebensstandard wesentlich niedriger
nach der wende fürchten einige russen
die ostdeutschen könnten rachegelüste
gegen ihre besatzer hegen
jürgen naumann ist damals schockiert
über den russischen sinneswandel
[Musik]
plötzlich waren es nicht mehr die
freunde da waren wir der feind
[Musik]
doch ernsthafte ausschreitungen bleiben
aus die russen ziehen ab
noch eine letzte militär parade dann
waren sie weg sie hinterließen munition
geschütze müll
die läden waren voll mit fernsehern
radios
kühlschränken und die wohnhäuser waren
noch komplett eingerichtet
bis ende 1994 hat der letzte russische
soldat das land verlassen
die kaserne fällt zurück an die deutsche
regierung sie steht immer noch leer
[Musik]
nur jürgen naumann kommt immer noch
regelmäßig
ich wünsche mir dass sich hier bald
wieder so hergerichtet wird
es ist nunmal geschichte
[Musik]
einst waren sie teil des kommunistischen
imperiums
heute sind sie verlassen und erinnern an
die dunklen zeiten vor dem fall der
berliner mauer
[Musik]